so what are the similarities between
somebody who is
physically fit and someone who is
financially fit right what are some
things we can learn from both of them
when you look at somebody who's
physically fit let's just say if you
were to hire a personal trainer
they are normally going to talk to you
and i about four different things
on how to become physically fit too
often we see somebody and we say oh my
goodness look at that guy
he looks so good look at her she looks
so good their six pack or how
toned they are how cut up they are or
their energy how they feel and
a lot of times we think it's just about
working out where eighty percent of it
has nothing to do with working out and
a personal trainer will tell you eighty
percent of being in shape
number one is your diet right so when
you look at someone and you talk to
personal trainer they say number one you
gotta have a good diet in place right
number
two is your body fat if you wanna be
physically fit we gotta lower your body
fat percentage number three
is your stamina your cardio is number
three number four is your strength
you're able
to push a lot more weight maybe your
legs get stronger maybe your core gets
stronger maybe your upper body gets
stronger
it's your strength so each one of them
is a different
discipline but you create a philosophy
on how to stay
physically fit all your life based on
those four areas you ever met somebody
who is very very strong but maybe their
cardio and their diet and their body fat
is weak
we met people like that before right you
ever met somebody that their cardio is
strong their stamina strong number three
but they're very weak
so it needs to be a balance of all four
together now
what does that have to do with becoming
financially fit where there's a lot of
similarities there's a lot of things the
parallels
on how that goes will become a wealthy
let's look at them number one
what it takes to have a discipline of
being physically fit
with your diet that's the same as the
discipline
of spending money you see people that
have savings or they're typically
not stressed out financially they have a
very strong discipline on spending
buying gifts buying presents splurging
they are disciplined in that area that's
the same as being disciplined on our
diet
number two the same as it goes with
their body fat percentage
people who are physically fit they keep
a low body fat percentage
is the same as those who are financially
fit they keep a high
credit score they watch and track their
credit cards credit score
on a monthly basis using some tools that
are out there truecredit.com or free
creditreport.com there's a lot of them
you can use to track your credit score
on a monthly basis just like somebody
who is physically fit
they keep track of their body fat on a
monthly basis number three what it takes
with the same when we said their cardio
level
or someone's stamina on the wealth
accumulation
site have a strong financial philosophy
and be financially fit
is your income too often people make
fifty thousand dollars a year and they
spend fifty thousand dollars a year so
the income problem is a problem
and we need to do something about that
that's the same as cardio because
when you have a strong income that
allows you to breathe and last a lot
longer
if your income is less you have a you
have a faster way of
running out of savings and that won't
help you become creative for your mind
to be free so you can really do the
things you want to do
and the last one is your strength when
you think about how strong you are with
your legs
your upper body with your core that
strength in working out being physically
fit
is a parallel in being financially fit
of your strength
in your savings how much money you have
in savings
how much money you have in cash how much
money you have in mutual funds how much
cash you have
in 401k ira how much money having
different investments out there
that take care of your expenses that
take care of your long term no matter
what happens
you're not worried about it because you
have a certain level of savings in place
so
just like it takes a certain set of
formula those four points to be
physically fit
it is very important for you and i to
discipline
ourselves in those four areas to become
financially fit
it's my message of the week to you and
by the way don't forget to subscribe